all right here now with reaction former
acting attorney general Matthew Whitaker
along with Fox News legal analyst Greg
Jarrett is with us uh good to see you
both Greg let's let's get your take I I
think you agree with me ABY L's a real
deal he got off uh Senator Menendez he
got off John Edwards he was Jared
kushner's lawyer um the the guy is
probably one of the top DC attorneys so
my question is what is his strategy here
no we'll do the public hearing but we
don't want to do the deposition part and
maybe uh hand over information you're
looking for us will that
work no it's not going to work Bluster
bravado
intimidation you know a subpoena Sean is
an order the law compels you to comply
you don't get to dictate terms but as
you say hunter Biden thinks he's special
and above the law so he's trying to
avoid a deposition where tough questions
by smart investigators who work for the
committee members they know the facts
they would confront Hunter with the
truth about his corrupt schemes
Financial records don't lie and the
committee to their credit has amassed
volumes of incriminating evidence of
bribery money laundering tax fraud
foreign lobbying crimes and look if
Hunter Biden lies under oath that's even
more crime so that's the reason why he's
demanding a public hearing because he
knows that probing questions are rare
members grandstand with their speeches
but he also who wants the usual Biden
sycophants like Jamie Rasin and Dan
Goldman to portray him as this poor
victim of drug addiction who should be
forgiven of his crimes but you know
addiction is not an excuse under the law
so the committee I think is absolutely
right to reject Hunter Biden's demands
what is your take Matt Whitaker what is
the strategy behind this the legal
strategy uh okay we want the public
hearing but uh we don't want to do that
deposition part that you're insisting on
um and I imagine that that would
probably be requesting of documents and
other information wouldn't
it yeah it would be and remember Abby
LOL knows exactly what he's doing he
knows that the the weakest part of this
case is if his client has to sit down
for directed uh questioning from a
council of the majority that can ask a
line of questions and not be interrupted
every 5 minutes uh by the rules of the
committee if it was public and so you
know this is just one part of their
defense obviously they're still facing
potential tax charges in California
there are the gun charges pending and
you know it's going to be very
interesting uh as I look at this whole
thing is you know uh chairman comr
mentioned uh uh Steve Bannon and that
reminds me of Peter Navaro as well who
were held in contempt who were
prosecuted by the doj and so you know
this is a high stakes game where you
know if if they can't come to some
agreement and he doesn't show up for
that subpoena deposition then he should
be held in contempt and prosecuted by
doj just like everybody else has been
well you're right if we had Equal
justice and application of our laws if
Justice was blind but we have a in my
view a weaponized Department of Justice
uh you know God only knows what would
happen but I would tend to think that uh
Hunter would not get the same treatment
as Bannon or Navaro in my view uh let me
let me ask you Greg Jared as as as
Hunter now goes forward with this and
when we talk about all of the suspicious
activity reports they have identified
tens of millions of dollars in
businesses that they can find no
services rendered for all of this money
10 Biden family members benefiting
financially then you have the very to me
the cut and dry case is the barisma case
Hunter admits he has no experience in
energy but he's got two massive energy
conglomerates one in Ukraine one in
China paying them a fortune for for what
at a time when he acknowledges he was
addicted to a to drugs at a time he
acknowledges he had no experience why
would they ever pay for for a hunter
that type of
money they wouldn't it was an illegal
quid proquo and you know the evidence is
overwhelming Sean that Hunter sold his
dad to the world China Russia Ukraine
Romania other countries over which Joe
Biden exercised influence he was bought
and paid for if you will and the family
got enormously riched by selling out
America in what has to be the biggest
bribery scandal in political history 150
suspicious activity reports as you point
out prove that tens of millions flowed
to Biden controlled shell companies then
funnel to family members Devon Archer
confirmed they were selling influence
and access to Joe he aided and embedded
his son's schemes in the barisma uh
Scandal conferring promises in exchange
for money I me you don't have to show
that Joe Biden pocketed a penny is still
a crime under the bribery statute if
cash goes to his family and of course
bribery is also an impeachable offense
Sean yeah you know Matt it's not illegal
to loan money but there seems to be as
chairman comr was pointing out a lot of
loans going on here uh I would imagine
that if a loan was made there would be
some record of it if if it wasn't
written down as a loan
certainly there's got to be a date a
time a method of payment that would
would back up that claim
right yeah not only that you would
expect a promisory note it's the only
way you could enforce that kind of debt
ultimately and you know the other thing
that I'm reminded of if if there's no
interest in all these loans if nobody's
paying interest they're paying principal
back that appears to be just a coverup
for these transactions but remember I
think exhibit number one that Hunter
Biden needs to answer the question about
is that text message that he sent his
own daughter where he asked is you know
she just should be happy that she
doesn't have to give 50% to her own dad
uh like Hunter has to and so I think
that's you know that's where the
committee those types of questions are
why this deposition needs to happen on
the 13th well I want to know if the $5
million doll loan was real that was
forgivable with no interest I want to
know if that's the case and if it is the
case then I want to request from both of
you that you give me those terms and $5
million I'm sure you would do that every
day of the week right cuz the minute you
gave it to me I would say thank you for
forgiving this you're not getting paid
back we'll see if that all pans out as
well uh Matt Whitaker Greg jar great to
see you both hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else